se confirma la salida del ejército
francés de malí un verdadero dolor de
cabeza logístico ya que la retirada
durará de 4 a 6 meses según el
presidente
y su efecto se llevará a cabo de forma
ordenada con las fuerzas armadas
malienses y la misión de las naciones
unidas en mali y durante este periodo
mantendremos nuestras misiones de apoyo
en la misma lucha por fin del mismo
concretamente las tres bases de gago
ximena que se vaciaran de los 2.400
soldados franceses de la operación
varian que participan en el seguimiento
de grupos terroristas en el sahel desde
más allá de barkhan la retirada
significará también el fin de las
fuerzas especiales tacuba creadas hace
menos de dos años cuyos soldados
europeos serán reubicados en la región
fronteriza de malí con el acuerdo de las
autoridades nigerianas los elementos
europeos se reposicionará junto a las
fuerzas armadas nigerianas en la región
fronteriza de mali
sin embargo parís reafirmó su voluntad
de seguir comprometida con los europeos
con los países del sahel y con el golfo
de guinea para continuar con la lucha
contra el terrorismo junto al presidente
ghanés y el consejo europeo
presidente senegalés dijo entender la
decisión francesa
acordamos con europa que la lucha contra
el sahel contra el terrorismo en el
sahel no sería responsabilidad exclusiva
de los países africanos en esto hay
consenso y es una suerte que se haya
renovado el compromiso de permanecer en
la región y reorganizar el dispositivo
parís prometió coordinar su retirada no
sólo con la misión de la onu en mali la
misma sino también con la misión de
formación de la unión europea malí de la
utm que seguirá beneficiándose del apoyo
aéreo y médico francés antes del
posterior y definitivo traspaso de estos
medios